You live in New York, where
you live in, in New York,
when Tribeca flooded a few years
ago, what was that like? Well,
I mean I think in a situation like that,
um,
most people emerge from a particular
disaster and think, my God,
since this is so awful,
it must be an anomaly.
And you know, I think New York was
really horrified as a city by Sandy,
but there's going to be, sandy is,
I don't remember the exact stat like
once every five years by the end of this
category storm Sandy, I think it
made landfall as a category three.
So it's not even a five.
Yeah. So if a five hidden,
is it possible for five to hit New York
as a too far north? No, as possible.
Totally possible.
I was talking to a really prominent
climate scientist a few months ago who is
like one of the, he was one of the
lead authors on the UN report, um,
lives in New York, does a lot of
consulting with the city. And I said,
so we're going to build a sea wall
to protect New York from flooding.
And he was like, oh, absolutely.
You know, Manhattan real estate,
it's way too expensive to let flood.
So we'll definitely build a seawall.
But an infrastructure project like
that takes at least 30 years to build.
And if we started right now,
we wouldn't be able to finish in time to
save Howard beach and parts of Brooklyn
and Queens. If we started
right now, he said, he said,
the city knows this and you'll
see in the next few years,
they'll stop doing
repairs on infrastructure.
They'll stop attending to the
subway lines in those neighborhoods.
And even a few years after that,
they'll start staying explicitly
to the people who live there.
You might be able to continue living
in these homes for a couple of decades,
but you're not going to be able to live
them, leave them to your kids. Whoa.
This is in New York City.
It's like the richest country in
the richest city in the world.
And he a huge parts of,
um,
huge parts of southern Brooklyn and
Queens are going to be underwater.
So for the people that live there right
now, what parts are you talking about? Um,
well the one that, the
one that he mentioned most
explicitly was Howard beach,
but, um, which is, it's kind of an inch.
It's like a mob neighborhood and you know,
it's still, yeah. Really well. Yeah. Yeah.
So cause that was like the
Gotti neighborhood, right? Yeah.
That's where they buried all
the dead bodies. Wow. Um,
I didn't know that was still a
mob neighborhood. Well, you know,
to the extent that there
is a mob. Yeah. Um,
and yeah, I mean that's true
everywhere on the coast, everywhere.
It's not just New York. New
York's not exceptional. You know,
their projections that like $30 billion
of New Jersey real estate could be
underwater by 20, 30, 20, 30.
Why does that not as alarming
was born in New Jersey. It's
not as alarming. And then,
you know, Miami beaches,
you know, Miami beach has done for, yeah.
Miami beach is almost inevitable. Correct?
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, you know,
they could, they could build
a seawall, but that, those,
that's not going to help because of the,
the ground. Right. It's just so expensive.
So you really have to,
um,
you really have to pick your poison and
then when you look around the world,
you know,
it's like Bangladesh,
that country is going to be
almost entirely underwater.
That's hundreds of millions of people.
If we wanted to build a seawall,
they can't afford that. Who's going to
afford, who's going to pay for that?
And this is all because of the raising
sea level because of the melting ice,
because of the temperature and all of
this is happening and I think, you know,
we think of sea level is really a
thing that happens on the coastline,
which it is primarily,
but it also increases flooding on rivers
because the water is all connected of
course.
So flooding in the UK is expected to
grow 50 folds by the end of the century.
What will that life d fold?
London is already like
underwater a couple times a year.
I mean not the whole city, but it
is this Jamie, this is Bangladesh.
I just went to oh dash underwater
video that pops up. Oh my God,
these people are fucked. Yeah. It
says 18 million residents live here.
That's a swamp. Yeah.
That looks crazy. Like it.
Like if you are a real estate projector
and you're flying over that like uh,
yeah, yeah, yeah. We
can't belt here. Yeah.
Jakarta will be totally underwhelmed
person as apartment buildings.
Like you could see the water level.
Look back up a little bit.
This is just a running little
thing. But if you see, look at like,
doesn't that look like
a water level on the,
the apartment buildings in the right
hand side near where your cursor is like,
like that's gonna go up to where
that orange level is fucking Christ.
Well, I mean over millennia where
they're going to rise hundreds of feet.
Oh God.
I mean it's going to take a long time
so you can adjust to that a little bit.
But um, but that's always
been the case, right? The,
they're still fine.
They find these artifacts and things
in the middle of the ocean areas where
people used to be able to live and
now they can't live anymore. Yeah,
I think that'll be, we have
to move, people have to
move. So what's a good spot?
Alberta, anywhere, anywhere,
anywhere. Off The tin.
That's the spot now. I mean I think I
would like that all the time. And I say,
you know,
honestly the place that I would move
to is somewhere in Scandinavia really
because, um, you know, I talked about
the impact of economic growth before,
but they're going to
be parts of the world,
the benefit economically from this
anywhere in the north. So Canada,
Russia and Scandinavia will benefit
because, but why don't go to Scandinavia,
go to Canada. It's right
there. Well let's get a,
seems kind of keep pretty hard to
me. I did that. Scandinavia is nice,
but Canada is like our neighbors,
they also,
they have wildfires there to Canada
and in the Arctic Circle in Finland,
bears and outlines. But so
you know, these, these guys,
the economists who study
this stuff say that, um,
there is actually an optimal
temperature for human productivity.
It's 13 degrees Celsius,
which is the historical media and
temperature of the u s it's also the
historical median temperature of Germany.
What does 13 Celsius?
Was that 60 degrees or
something like that?
And I think it's like in the high fifties.
Well,
we've got Jamie,
Google doesn't give it to you,
right whenever I'm in Canada,
I'm always like, I don't know what you're
saying. Yeah. They're like, Holy Shit,
it's 22 degrees, 55. Um,
and so for every degree north of that
you lose about a percentage point of GDP.
So the u s is now at about 13 and a
half a degree Celsius at our media and
temperature.
That means that we're losing about a
half percentage point of GDP every year
from it.
But there are parts of the u s that were
cooler than 13 and are now brought up
to this optimal level. Silicon valley is
like exactly at 13 degrees right now. Um,
which is,
you know,
notable cause they're like super
productive and that's going to be,
so that'll be true for
Scandinavian generally.
And it may be part of the explanation
why there's been so much economic
productivity in Scandinavia over the
last generation is that they have already
started doing better with temperature.
Crops are going to be
more bountiful in Russia.
Like Russia will have better
agriculture because of global warming,
which is why they make
such a, you know, there,
there is such a complicated figure in
the geopolitical story about climate.
So they are a petro state.
They have almost all of their economic
activity activity has to do with burning
oil, but there are also poised
to benefit from warming.
So they're doubly motivated to produce
more global warming and they have such a
fuck the rest of the world perspective
that they're not going to stop.
Whereas Canada probably
they're like likely to,
even though they'd
benefit from more warming,
they'll probably get on board with any
program to avert warming. But that is a,
um, that's a dilemma that
faces every nation. You know,
like Justin Trudeau gets,
you know,
talks a lot of shit about Donald
Trump and his climate policy, but he,
Justin Trudeau is also approving new
pipelines on Glen. Marco does the same,
but she is retiring,
um,
nuclear so quickly in Germany that
they're having to use dirty energy. Um,
and even though they've had this
incredible green energy revolution there,
their emissions are going up. Um,
and every country in the world is,
it's a collective action problem.
Every country in the world is incentivized
to behave badly and let the rest of
the world clean up the mess.
So I was talking to this guy yesterday
about wildfires and he was like, you know,
California is doing so great, you know,
with all of the emission standards,
they're basically,
you know,
holding themselves to the Paris accords
even though the country as a whole isn't,
but that impact isn't local.
It's global. So it's dissipated.
The temperature impact on California
wildfires will be determined by it.
Like I said earlier, basically what
China does. So in terms of, you know,
what any individual area with any,
any individual nation is doing,
the motivations are really,
really complicated there.
And in California in particular,
this is a bit of a tangent, but um,
you know, the state has done incredible
stuff with emission standards,
fuel efficiency,
green energy,
and yet all of those gains now are wiped
out every year by the fires because
fires are trees,
trees or burning trees are basically
coal in the sense that they are stored
carbon when they burn,
they release carbon into the atmosphere.
So every time there are wildfires like
they were last year in California,
it literally wipes out all of the
progress that the state made in all of its
green initiatives that year. Um, yeah,
and you know about in, in,
in, in Brazil, the, um,
the president of Brazil wants to
like basically de forest, the Amazon,
the Amazon is responsible for something
like 30% of the world's oxygen, um,
and is a huge, so all plants obviously
absorb carbon and produce oxygen.
Um, to plant life is really good
for fighting climate change.
When you say he wants a divorce, the
Amazon, at what scale? What does he,
what does he talk about doing?
So the scientists who have studied his
proposal say that his plans would be the
equivalent of adding
over a 10 year period,
adding a second China to the
world's global footprint.